I want to take us right down to the
ground from the heights of aspiration
that Richard was just talking about down
where I live with the lawyers and I and
and and I want to begin by by noting
that Richard spoke of General Joseph
Smith as he often referred to himself
and and he understood himself as a
military as well as a political and a
religious figure and I want to pick up
with the idea that war is is often
called politics by other means and I
want to pull us further from that to the
other end of the spectrum and argue that
law is productively thought of often as
politics by other means and that lawyers
often function as politicians using
courts and legal arguments to accomplish
their political objectives now even if
you don't yet agree with me bear with me
as I put together something of a history
of law and lawyers after Joseph Smith's
murder and the latter day saints
migration westward through statehood so
so from about 18 46 47 through 1896 i'll
be talking about the way lawyers
functioned in territorial utah see what
i mean on the ground I'm not only in
official roles as prosecutors and judges
but also as a defense bar defending
defending accused Mormons in the end the
development of this talented legal
community made a difference to the
history of the territory and the church
that made the great base in its home
they did so mostly through law and legal
action not war and pillage but
nonetheless they made politics there are
three sections to my paper the first
focuses on us
mighty virtually without professional
attorneys perish the thought right this
section talks about why and how that
came about and what the consequences
were the second section examines
especially the 1870s and the change in
approach that brought brought lawyers
into the picture both in Utah and in
Washington representing church interests
as well as opposing them the final
section talks about the effects of this
new legal community which included
Mormons as well as non-mormons in the
end Utah in 1896 when it was formally
admitted as a state looked a lot like
other states the Latter day Saints had
smart lawyers to call on as they
navigated the 20th century just as other
groups in that sense I'm talking about a
pattern of growing legalism with lawyers
prohibited from plying their craft in
the first period then in the second
period acts ain't acting both for and
against as defense counsel on
prosecutors and finally coming together
to draft a constitution and assuming
important posts in a new political
jurisdiction in my final period so what
I want to argue is this isn't part of a
more standard historians view of an
American ization of Utah for statehood I
instead I want to argue that lawyers
were key to the negotiations that
brought resolution to a long and painful
conflict and in some sense lawyers were
indeed dangerous to Zion whether they
were Mormon or not they helped undo
tissues of difference that separated
Mormons from Gentiles I and they found
common ground as they litigated in the
1870s and 80s so I like to think of this
as a legalization of Utah for statehood
a refinement of prior work
based on research into the role of
lawyers in bringing change so I'm
calling my first section order without
lawyers let me just quickly set this
stage not having lawyers doesn't mean
not having law the latter-day saints
were a deeply law bound people right
from the earliest period but they were
not enamored of the legal profession far
from it they shared their dislike of
lawyers with many other Americans then
and now but they took anti lawyer ism to
new heights and often mixed in with that
disdain for significant parts of the
American legal system especially the
common law not so much the
constitutional law I'll focus working in
our chronological pattern on Brigham
Young mostly in its talk in part because
I'm particularly interested in this
pattern in Utah but also because his
resistance to lawyers is so important to
the unfolding of the story and the
eventual rise of a profession that young
distrusted and even despise the rise of
that profession to positions of
significant power in the ongoing
governance of the new state of Utah I'm
calling this section order without
lawyers draws on the work of recent
legal theorists who argue that it's
possible to have well-functioning
communities without the presence of law
I think they they've made a mistake
there they mean without the presence of
lawyers they they are talking about
formalities of law and those who enforce
them and and in that sense they're
arguing against the existence of lawyers
you see what I mean people dislike
lawyers and all periods of American
history but i consider myself lovable
yeah so Brigham Young would have agreed
with these scholars about order without
law and if Joseph Smith focused on
harmony as a political virtue then
Brigham Young considered the essence of
what lawyers did as bringing disharmony
and discord and and many utopian
communities and ideas draw on this idea
that lawyers bring trouble you can hear
it all the time you know once the
lawyers get involved the divorce turns
ugly and it would have been friendly
before that this is a common theme and
I'm not saying it's wrong but I just
want us to notice it so Jung was deeply
opposed to lawyers litigation and
especially the common law the English
legal inheritance of the United States
Louis suits between Mormons were
strongly discouraged young especially
condemned litigation as in here I'm
quoting an even evil that opens a wide
door when indulged in for the admission
of every unclean spirit among the first
acts of the Deseret legislature was a
passage was passage of a statute
forbidding collection of lawyers fees
Mormons were encouraged in the strongest
terms to bring disputes to the local
bishop who would resolve the
disagreement or send parties on to the
ecclesiastical courts a ghost court
system run by the church that handled
the nuts and bolts of internal dispute
resolution throughout the territorial
period and even beyond litigation
between Mormons and non-mormons was
handled by the local probate courts
whose jurisdiction was extensive usually
probate courts we think of them today as
handling questions of wills estates
guardianship and so on in Utah the
Mormon controlled legislature granted
probate courts the power to heal here
all civil
as well as all criminal cases probate
judges were elected to four-year terms
and in many cases the local bishop and
judge of the ecclesiastical court was
also the probate judge so you could
change hats in in various different
places these courts also drew up jury
lists the legislature also expressly
prohibited the courts from citing
precedents from any other jurisdiction
and in particular legal technicalities
were to be avoided as young put it
lawyers and their technicalities were
specious pretentious and survial keeping
the people hostage to quote the musty
rubbish of Ages gone yes the
extraordinary power of these probate
courts were a recipe for charges of
partiality Mormon control of judges
jurors juries and of course the
prohibition of lawyers led Mormons to
conclude non-mormon excuse me to
conclude that they could not get justice
in these courts in particular selection
of juries through probate courts
guaranteed that no jury even those
impaneled in the federal courts of the
territory would enforce anti-polygamy
lot laws federal judges sent to Utah as
well as non-mormons in the territory
complete let complain loud and long
about the futility of in tempting to
enforce these laws by the late 1860's
even federal judges acknowledged that
the first anti bigamy statute passed in
1862 was now a dead letter as they
called it in Utah Mormons replied that
the law was unconstitutional anyway so
lack of enforcement was just evidence of
the laws fundamental invalidity rather
than their own lawlessness you can see
and away we go right
up for 20 years Mormons had the best of
this argument and some scholars have
claimed that the law dealt by the
probate courts was rough but also
roughly fair lawyers of course were
always and passionately opposed to the
probate court system these included
ambitious young men who came to utah
during or after the Civil War hoping to
build careers in mining law and found
themselves a despised micro minority
within a small but larger an embattled
non-mormon community in Utah in the
1860s even more territorial efficient
officials who were hired by the federal
government and told to go to Utah and
enforce the law found themselves frozen
out their livelihoods dependent on
persuading Washington that they and
legal process rather than the army
politics by military means that legal
process was the best way to save Utah
and its benighted inhabitants right from
the clutches of religious fanaticism
these federal officials were natural
conduits for anti-polygamy their
presence in the territory both reflected
anti Mormonism in the east and then in
turn bolstered it further especially
when they pointed to departures from the
law and practice in the rest of the
country and broadcast their complaints
back to Washington and so on it becomes
a cycle the order without lawyers that
Mormons hope to create looked more and
more to the outside world like a society
gone badly wrong and something had to
give so I call my next section loitering
up
gradually it became evident that defense
of Zion required legal expertise
pressure from Congress and territorial
judges including the revocation of the
incorporation of the church indictments
of Brigham Young and other Mormon
leaders for lewd and lascivious
cohabitation legal proceedings against
mormons for polygamy and the mountain
meadows massacre and in the end very
complex litigation surrounding Brigham
Young's estate all contributed to the
development of a legal strategy to
defend the church lawyers soon followed
both Mormon and non-mormon as debates
over Mormon distinctiveness and
religious rights flowed into legal
channels by the early 1870s Brigham
Young himself had been arrested sued for
alle alimony by an estranged plural wife
his adopted son john d lee had been
excommunicated and was under
investigation for his part in the
mountain meadows massacre and the
jurisdiction of the probate courts and
their powers over jurors had been
sharply reduced by new law from
Washington these setbacks occurred as
Young himself lost some of his edge to
old age he died in 1877 his opposition
to lawyers had long deterred young
Mormon men from pursuing careers in the
law but now young began to relent the
career of Franklin Richards illustrates
the potential and perils created by
Young's conclusion that now he needed
loyal Mormon lawyers Richard's were
called 60 years later that young took
him aside as a very young man and
advised him to study the law after he
read alone in other words he had no one
to mentor him Richards was admitted to
the bar in 1874 he he was the first
fresh Mormon face among a growing
non-mormon legal community
served as general counsel to the church
for 30 years and was excuse me perennial
co-counsel on briefs to the United
States Supreme Court often appearing at
oral argument is a backup to whatever
you know fancy hired gun sitting senator
or whoever the church had hired to argue
a case at the Supreme Court he and his
firm defended prominent Mormons at trial
and on appeal in Salt Lake and Ogden as
well now Richards never took a plural
wife instead he quietly but consistently
resisted polygamy remaining monogamous a
practice he argued that helped promote
cooperation and economic development in
the state Richards was so successful at
mediating between Mormons and federal
officials that eventually he became the
law partner of former prosecutor Charles
Varian who was widely attacked by the
Mormon press in the 1880s as a virulent
anti-mormon in other words these people
work to cross the street you know they
they would cross sides very comfortably
other Mormon lawyers followed a similar
path and gradually built an articulate
and successful defense bar Joseph
Rollins for example hung out his shingle
in the mid-1870s and handled many
complex and delicate matters for the
church including polygamy defense work
and parts of the litigation surrounding
the Brigham Young estate Rawlins was
also a monogamist and he took the
leading role in the establishment of the
Democratic Club of Utah in 1880 for
several other young lawyers were
prominent members of the club among home
excuse me we're Richards and others
whose names appeared frequently as
defense
in the flood of anti-polygamy
prosecution that dominated the life of
the territory by the mid 1880s the
Democratic clubs official platform
includes this statement quote we firmly
repudiate the idea that any citizen is
under obligation to take his political
counsel from those who whose avowed
purpose is a continued violation of law
that is this organization that included
leading young Mormon lawyers departed
sharply growth from the admonition
commonly attributed to Young and his
successors and advisors that polygamy
must be defended at all costs instead
this political Club endorsed obedience
to law as the means of advancement so
let me let me come to my third section
which I'm calling the bar and the
Brethren isn't it ironic that lawyers
are called the bar anyway ironically the
prominence of these young lawyers within
their profession was achieved through
defending in court a practice that they
did not follow in their private lives
like the trained professionals they were
though Richards and other lawyers
crafted plausible legal arguments in
defense of their clients and they had
impressive wins forcing prosecutors and
judges to crest craft new and far less
devastating methods and strategies yet
most of the lawyers in this story did
well Mormon as well as non mormon and I
want to point to the exceptions that
kind of prove the rule which are two
older lawyers aurelius minor and zaruba
bells no I hope I'm pronouncing his
that's how we say it okay um they had
both faded from view by the 1880s and
minor especially was despised by the
federal bench he had been he had been a
relatively active practitioner
eventually he was found guilty of
unlawful cohabitation in eighteen eighty
five and he served six months in prison
he was then disbarred from legal
practice but his professional biography
doesn't even mention the conviction
aside from a few incidents such as
miners conviction the legalization of
Utah was swift and it was successful
Utah went from a territory where lawyers
influence was banned in 1851 to a place
where lawyers called many of the shots
all in about 35 years a generation in
other words in his great study of the
territorial southwest the yale historian
howard lamar remarked on generational
differences in utah in the late 1880s he
argued that the latter-day saints who
had begun in the 1830s with a useful and
a youthful excuse me and physically
powerful leadership were now governed
more by graybeards wise old men wilford
woodruff for example was 82 years old
when he became church president in 1889
George q cannon was 20 years younger
much more modern than Woodruff but the
guys I'm talking about our 40-somethings
our Richards and Rawlins and so on these
this coterie of lawyers in the 1880s
were the ones who ushered in a new age
of professional specialization a far cry
from the sort of jack of all trades that
someone like cannon and the earlier
generations were i also want to pick up
on
us focus on change across generations
and emphasize the profession that marked
these men as thinkers and actors in Utah
the lawyers managed reconciliation
they're helping craft a workable
framework for government what they
eventually settled on was a draft
constitution that closely tracked the
structures of government in other states
and were a product of loyola thinking
and that have consistently placed
lawyers in positions of power the
pattern is a familiar one to students of
American history the history and John
Miren of Princeton studied colonial
Massachusetts and found excuse me a
roughly parallel track for legal culture
there and for the culture of legalism
with this with its embrace of formality
of argument and procedure clearly
defined standards and precedents and so
on and just to give you a sense of how
well this worked for the lawyers I just
double checked yesterday to make sure I
was right 26 out of 44 United States
presidents have been lawyers forty-five
percent of Congress currently is
composed of lawyers more than quadrupled
the next largest profession when the
Constitutional Convention in Utah
convened in 1895 to draft the document
that would finally admit the territory
as a state all of our lawyers were there
these leading members of the Mormon
defense bar met with prosecutors and
judges who had sent Mormon polygamists
to jail and excluded all Mormon men from
jury pools together they buried the
political and religious differences that
had been so divisive only two decades
earlier as a group with a shared
vocabulary and shared goals these men
figured prominently at the convention
and replicated as
I said the basic structures of other
American American governments they
resolved the fundamental question that
had so dominated Utah history ending the
battle that had created the bench and
bar and brought them the lawyers to
power polygamy they concluded would
forever be a felony in Utah but if the
lawyers and legal profession generally
were the beneficiaries of the long and
bitter anti-polygamy campaign there were
also clear losers and I'm not going to
talk about the most obvious ones the
poor guys who went to jail let me put
point to some other ones because we
often don't remember their losses the
focus of the campaign against polygamy
gradually yet steadily excluded women in
the 1870s and even the early 80s women's
organizations could realistically be
considered the vanguard of anti-polygamy
activism and equally important to its
defense women such as analyzed a web
young who divorced and claimed that ala
me alimony I was talking about against
Brigham Young and then went on a
spectacularly successful nationwide
lecture tour and Angie Newman who
campaigned for an industrial Christian
home for escape plural wives found
themselves sidelined over the course of
the 1880s and Eliza was a sensation when
Brigham Young was alive and powerful and
Angie Newman argued strenuously that
women should have a refuge from
patriarchy as she constantly called it
but once the prosecution's began in
earnest both women lost their public
following analyze a Young's career
collapsed in the 1880s and she fell into
such
security that even her place and date of
death are unknown Angie Newman was
outraged she just sputters you can read
it on the page when she learned that the
industrial home she had fought for and
which was supposed to temper justice
with woman's mercy was in fact turned
over to men the moment it was built you
guessed it the three territorial judges
and the federal prosecutors all lawyers
made up the board of the home together
with the governor Caleb West yep another
lawyer within three years the industrial
home became not a refuge but a poorhouse
and within just over six years it had
closed on the unanimous recommendation
of its all-male governing board another
group of women also lost in the shift
from to law as the primary vector for
anti-polygamy as is so often the case in
criminal trials the purported victim
gradually faded from public view the
actors in these prosecutions both
defense and prosecutors were exclusively
male it was men who accused tried and
defended other men and I don't want as
minimums the suffering of Mormon men who
were sent to prison for living their
religion but the battle against polygamy
had begun under the banner of the
protection of women in a Democratic
Society women's respect and so on as
essential to an American state and it
was defended in the early days on many
of the same grounds like defenses of
polygamy argued on its superiority the
capacity to guarantee a husband for
every woman on motherhood the duties of
men to their wives and so on the project
prosecutions of the late 1870s through
the early 1890s exposed women to the law
not only
as their husbands were incarcerated
women were called upon to be witnesses
in thousands of cases they struggled to
be loyal and faithful and yet also to
tell the truth often they failed to
minute to manage these contradictory
mandates dozens of women were prosecuted
for perjury hundreds more perjured
themselves out of desperation Mormon
women became known as Liars almost 200
women were also prosecuted for
fornication a crime typically reserved
for prostitutes and the odd serving girl
who got pregnant on the job in
territorial Utah women who were
understood in their communities as
upstanding and face it chased were
charged as fornicators they have been
left out of the historical scholarship
and even accounts at the time an
oversight that no doubt reflects the
shame of the fornicator label but that
should not be replicated through
historians focus on men alone last and I
promise to circle back to this so you
know I'm winding up is the army as a
loser it was a constant presence in the
background sometimes in the foreground
such as in the Utah war of the 1850s
most of the time Mormon defendants and
territorial officials avoided violence
both had strategic interests in avoiding
the armed intervention that would surely
follow outright violence Mormons knew
well not only after the Utah war but
even more centrally after the Civil War
that open rebellion or even sustained
rhetorical challenge to the power of the
national government could not be a
winning tactic Mormon defendants and the
church as a whole were committed to a
policy of resistance that fell just
short of provoking martial law
territorial court personnel had a
related interest
they wanted to keep law rather than war
the means of political change because
their jobs depended on the perception
that the court system was the most
effective and efficient read cheapest I
am I am this is my final but it's so
great right lawyers are cheaper than
soldiers it's hard to believe means of
dealing with with defiance of federal
law in Utah in the process right all of
these lawyers created ten connective
threads between Saints and Gentiles
establishing political as well as leave
legal avenues for cooperation even as
they fought bitterly against each other
in court in the end law and government
in Utah followed well-worn paths and we
wound up with a political government
that looks a lot like those in other
states many scholars argue that conflict
is essential to American government and
constitutional structure in that sense
lawyers who manage and channel conflict
rather than harmony for example are
predictable and even useful political
actors and what they did was bring Utah
politics firmly into the standard and
and much complained about control of
lawyers